okay last like side ancillary story from
this event that took place in Michigan
this Trump rally in Michigan which is
just completely and totally wild I do
have a couple of Mike pillow Clips here
Mike pillow also known as Mike Lindell
the CEO and founder of Mike pillow he
was at the Trump rally in Warren
Michigan he was interviewed by right
side broadcasting and he made the claim
that the FBI found him at the Hardys
Where They seized this phone because
they illegally put some kind of a
tracking device on him now does he have
any proof of this no he doesn't it's
like one o'clock or no like I guess 11
30. how did they know where you were
were they following you no
how did they know they tracked me
illegally they tracked my tracking
device yeah or my phone we don't know
yet we're trying to get to the bottom of
that but what they did we just don't
know you know if they had a suspicion
that pillow was in town they probably
just said let's just wait at Hardee's
he's probably bound to show up
eventually in all seriousness isn't the
tracking device his phone like we all
carry these phones around and we mostly
all have GPS enabled like is it he's
willingly carrying it around until the
FBI took it because Mike pillow really
not making too much sense
um and then oh one more pillow clip from
the rally here he was kind of jumping on
the some Republicans or bad train saying
that the Republicans nominated in
Georgia aren't good and but by the way
what he means by that is that the
Republicans in Georgia weren't as
willing as he wanted them to be to try
to just give George's electoral votes to
Trump even though Biden won we're doing
a class a class action lawsuit against
okay anyway here's the explanation
and because they're Republicans yeah
what's better what's to me there's
nothing worse than evil evil doesn't
show sides right evil doesn't show
um oh you're a Republican or you're a
Democrat no it holds no bounds so you
have the I believe the worst three
Republicans in history down in Georgia
ever ever and because of the cover-up
that they've done and then here you yeah
so what he means is I would like them to
have given Trump Georgia even though
Biden won it that's effectively what
Mike pillow is saying here uh and then
Meanwhile by the way
if he's saying these three are the bad
candidates by definition it means that
Herschel Walker in Georgia must be a
good candidate which is laughable and
also really really scary so that's all
the stuff I want to talk about from
Michigan we heard from Trump we heard
from the audience members we heard from
Marjorie Taylor green and now we heard
from Mike pillow you tell me who's the
scariest I I kind of lean towards it's
the audience because without the
audience none of these people get any
attention but because they have
followers they have influence and that
is truly truly sick stuff